Does hot water freeze faster than cold water?
The obvious answer seems to be no because all else being equal,...
...the hot water first has to cool down to the same temperature as the cold water...
...and do everything the cold water has to do in order to freeze.
So it must take longer, right?
Well, not according to the Mpemba Effect.
This effect is named after Erasto Mpemba who in 1963 was a Tanzanian student...
...making ice cream as a school project.
The students were meant to boil a mixture of cream and sugar...
...and then let it cool down before putting it into the freezer...
...but worried about not getting a spot,...
...Mpemba put his mixture into the freezer immediately after boiling it...
...and returning an hour and a half later, he found that his mixture had frozen...
...while his classmates had not.
Mpemba was intrigued by this phenomenon...
...and eventually enlisted the help of a physics professor Dennis Osborne...
...to investigate the effect using cream and also water.
And they managed to replicate Mpemba's finding and published a physics paper...
...stating that warm water does indeed freeze faster than cold.